I'm looking at Brendan's very glowy face
you got a trick knee huh okay what you
got a little trick knee yeah I like me
I'm not used to hearing you being in
trouble hold on I might so I met with my
peeps yesterday yeah your knee people my
knee my peeps my knee girl yeah Negro
Negro me girl
[ __ ] [ __ ] me girl girl yeah yeah be
careful sounds like a negro I see now
girl any girl any girl any girl Negro
yeah all right so I met with her and um
you know I did this it's a meniscus MCL
hold on another AC oh hold on hold on
let me guess it's in your calf the
problems in you cap it wrong Ellen [ __ ]
Brian again try to pretend he knows
about the physical [ __ ] mechanics ah
no it's my one of my quad muscles just
shut went dormant decided to shut down
oh [ __ ] yeah so that that's so weird
because for real like I've heard that
sometimes your I had a my knee hurt I'm
sorry to interrupt people is my knee
hurt and the guy goes roll out your
thigh and I said what and he was a
powerlifting coach and I go what and I
did in it my knee went away so yeah
mindful more serious than that they said
it's because of 25 years of athletics
yeah all right now I've done a lot of
sports to they said after 25 years I've
been doing you can relate to this yeah
they said especially since fighting and
playing football since I'm always my
hips always back on my passos board that
that part of my leg has quit firing like
my brain the neurons have quit fire in
there so when I run its overcompensating
it's like so tight so they set up this
like stem unit like this super intense
I've seen stem units before they have me
do all these drills with it I guess stay
on it is it because you have tightness
in your in your hips now it's because
the the way my hips have been aligned
for so long from football riding being
back that part wasn't really required to
my glutes and that part of my quad
aren't firing correctly man that's that
David so much about body yeah and so
they also said after chain
my running form like I've run I'm Swiss
run my hips back and I have two hips
forward so can you do exercises to bring
your hips forward yeah yeah but yeah
changed my running gait and stuff like
that and then I went whoa I thought
you're gonna tell me I need to lose like
25 pounds she was what do you weigh well
I I'm like 240 right now 238 she's like
it wouldn't hurt yeah you don't really
have a lot to weight to lose that's why
I was like if you tell me to do it I'll
do it just a big and I was like do you
think I'm just too big to run she goes
no I bigger people than you run at
people are 80 years old who run it's not
that's the way you run yeah I said do
things in the shoes she uh maybe you
gotta choose like it's this yeah it's
cool and this place is it's in uh how
does she figure did that happen how did
she figure that out so she did a bunch
of tests oh my how many to see what was
fired like what where it hurt and she
goes if you were perfectly in tune that
none of this would hurt it all fire well
it's like for me the the my back hurt
for Oh 20 years 25 years I don't know
and the so Lauren Landau and my buddy
Leo flowers were like you know it's your
glutes
it's your so as it's the your front hip
I'm like it doesn't make sense my back
hurts my lower back so why would my
glutes and once I loved tonight yeah and
and then also they were big on sort of
like my posterior tilt so my hips were
tilted back and when I when I did
exercise to bring them forward I swear
to god I've talked to you about this I
don't have back problems anymore but do
working on the [ __ ] that I didn't think
having doesn't you know that's not my
back I'm not actually feeling like I'm
doing any with my back so I go to her
every I gotta go to them it's kind of
annoying I just OSHA's a one-trick pony
which then they have PRP there they have
stem cell you know injections stuff like
that much can't you just do that and I
get bail got it she's like well it was a
hell yeah shock the shoots would like
yeah she's been doing it forever and she
works with the you know the Olympic
soccer team and like yeah people like
that amaze me how they can picture she
knew right away and then she was like
shouldn't she goes what are those things
or that you ask it talks you can say
it's like Siri but Sam's on it so I
think you know I'm thinking like oh no
you know what talking about anyways they
had one of those shoes
kind of means you like to work out till
Mike will work out I thought she was
like give me a massage something she's
like oh no we're gonna do work we're
gonna do some working in a sweat she was
sweaty was you have shorts on it no I
came my jeans came in from the studio
she goes we're in arcade we're gonna
sighs do you around like I guess Excel
and large it's okay we're gonna be smart
shorts and then it's time to work so
what do you like to work out there I was
like I know I was like Drake she goes I
forget what they caught she's all Siri
Drake and it starts playing this she's
like I'm gonna connect these want to
find the I'm gonna get myself into a
little nightie
I wish oh yeah not bad so yeah when we
get to that so off here but so then she
goes around with this Tim you know where
it hurts
yeah and hold up this thing goes to a
hundred power and I go what's that she
goes that's had an eight and I she goes
now listen this isn't a ego thing you
don't have to act tough she goes I have
some people in here where it won't start
working we got to get you 18 before we
start singing so a result so 18s the
bare minimum she goes I've had
professional skateboarders in here I
don't understand what what do you mean
by 18 so so electricals yeah charge so
between 1 to 118 is where it starts to
kick in or starts to kick in and you're
you start fine okay so she's fine she
goes so we I get to 18 and she goes in
our slowly start after you tell me when
you feel it so there's one can I tear
here and on my back yeah so it's all
like running through and then eventually
I have it connected on both legs back in
class I'm like in doing these workouts
so I go I'm like ah and she's all
remembered it can't hurt you
this isn't gonna hurt you so just about
your pain tolerance and dealing with it
oh no doubt because you got a high pain
tolerance not really I hate tattoos and
uh when I stub my toe I will solve it
all falling 30 minutes anyways when I
hit my beats on the side top of cable or
paper cut there was my minute there was
no let me finish
so she turns it on and I'm like oh my
gosh you just gotta get through it and
I'm like what are we at she thought you
had a 16 and I'm like well what do
people usually do she goes it literally
ghin this isn't the ego thing just a
pinch cos I have some people in here
like some professional basketball
players we it's like a sick
and they're dying she goes and then I'll
have like professional skateboarders and
they're not like in 80 wide she goes
could they get this [ __ ] all the time
and then she I figured with your
fighting background football you'd be
able you know like 20 or 30 I'm like oh
no no no no I'm a giant [ __ ] with when
it comes to pain so the least possible
and she goes I have an 80 year old who
can get to a hundred oh my and then I
went why and so when she's telling these
numbers like whatever it's just on 16
and then put on both legs after these
exercises and workout like squats all
this I'm sweating pretty hardcore at
this time and so she has on she goes now
just give me 10 squats from the table up
and we're gonna crank it up she cranks
up doing I think 28 and I went oh what
the [ __ ] someone does a hunter skis yeah
I went [ __ ] [ __ ] he's that crazy
guy was like [ __ ] no one's doing
this she goes I promise you like this is
your not because when she was searching
for it like that search and it'll start
firing where it's all [ __ ] up you know
like the spots woman after so after like
cross you know crossing for the
connections right
and once you searching for it I might
you know me I'm a Chatty Cathy and she
her husband plays rugby I'm talking I'm
just trying to create dialogue because
she's all my goddamn leg so it's not
awkward yeah and we're talking and she's
like not just you know when you feel it
you know let me know and it went it hit
I couldn't talk oh yeah she was that
telling that you know what that's it she
has these pads that have all electricity
going through because I I remember
electricity is nananana joke if you
think like he can kill you
well it's certainly so well she goes now
remember no one's ever been hurt from
this like yeah here's what they do if I
have a heart bad ticker yeah I like
trizzie you know what they what a lot of
they like to do with political enemies a
lot of times in certain countries is
they'll get you in a room and you'll be
an ankle deep water and then they'll
just they'll just Electrify the water
that doesn't feel good well you're
talking about tango and cash went in
prison when they both young the drop in
the water
well yes yep or they'll just take a live
wire and just apply them to you balls
now here's what you guys need to know I
was 18 years old 18 spades with my girl
girl no it was with my girl and there
was a Clydesdale horse there were
Clydesdale horses
my choice behind a what what I guess the
kind of electric fence that keeps a
Clydesdale from jumping it's a dinosaur
yeah why you'd want to keep quiet I
guess they'll bust through a fence
anyway I said to my girl I'm gonna touch
that she goes don't however you get this
done 18 make sense I was like yeah right
you tryin to I check this way with my
immortality I go do it cuz man and
you're trying to impress her caveman
stuff man me rock bash there you go me
touch we're drunk we I had some Paul
Masson wine we had a little picnic
entire Rock Lord sure was probably
wasn't anymore because I worked my magic
on her oh yeah and by magically lay down
my magic when I met in exile yeah I want
to grow at acre close out my back don't
move - yeah too late
like like talk about a prison it's out
mayonnaise I was a premature ejaculator
all the way through my twenties dad not
me do nothing I mean through my twenty
never too late I'm really not me I don't
think I think I was able to really bear
down until I was probably 25 26 oh well
yeah maybe even later I'll turn around
so you touched the fence yeah touch the
fence but I did it I did a slice right
through where I went dead like that like
chin touch in the dinner table [ __ ] it
hurts so bad my finger okay like like
like I get it yeah the only sound to
make if you ever sound brother yeah hey
hey like it was so not sexy either oh my
god what a girl thing it was the worst
it was the [ __ ] I can't imagine pissing
on that if you had to piss on a [ __ ]
spark plug good luck I can't imagine
there's certain things where you just
you can't act um yeah like if you if you
get the wind knocked out of you oh boy
pick up football son hit you in there
weird me you're not the worst
well you um add to all the years of
sports though you have very few injuries
yeah this isn't even really technically
any nuts in it yeah yeah yeah she was we
were going through my sports history and
she's like uh
and you don't have surgery no just have
the one hand surgery like this
like what the [ __ ] that is amazing not
even Z's or anything I what I like to do
one time I heard Matt Mitrione cuz
speaking of doing sports for 25 years
the other day you would I say certain
things that I won I'm glad you're not
there cuz you're right you're so
embarrassed yeah you know let me tell
the story before you get this one we me
and Brian were doing set it the Phoenix
stand up live in Phoenix I leave I don't
he gets there before me in the room
there's comics going on before us then
we're doing firing kid life and I go
Brian goes early and he's there with a
comics in green room and I'm I just
sneak in and Brian's telling a fight
story to these four comics and they're
looking up just throwing and throwing my
tea and he's my hand he's going the
other than that one [ __ ] came out
dead sit now what can you what are you
doing it goes oh what's up like I got
caught I hands
like I my wet fellows the lie you guys
are buying this [ __ ] and they're
like you talking about master Kalyn like
oh hell yes when I'm not here this out
okay so this is even worse so my
babysitter our nanny just pretty girl
pretty girl is the new one new one is
haven't seen her in four pretty and so
Swedish one she got deported
unfortunately but that's she was so hot
this the joke I make is that some women
could like they could be like I have Hep
C and I'm a shoplifter and you'd be like
should I have AIDS like God they figured
that magic can make it no this is good
but I remember one time Matt Mitrione
was talking about he's an athlete he's a
great athlete he said he said something
really cool he said I've always been the
guy he was talking we're getting older
and he goes but I've always been the guy
that my body will do whatever I tell it
to right so physically like he can he's
just a physically gifted athlete so he
could play pro football but he was
talking about fighting until age six up
until father times huh
that's what he said so he's guys then
father time and you start to feel it
where you're like your body's not doing
what you can tell but I thought it was a
cool way for an athlete describe how
gifted they are physically so I remember
that that was probably four years you
regurgitate that and and so I know I
told you that I had a good
coughing experience cuz a pro happened
to have been there and the pro basically
said you could be really good at golf
now I'm 50 in other words he said you
could be really good at golf I took that
to mean I'm obviously he said you know
your body you know the first thing with
the I haven't seen Brian I don't know
how many days person tells me because
listen Browns good he's dead serious
it's not jacket really cuz hey come here
this is this I know it's gonna be a
terrible story and I probably should
tell you shut the [ __ ] up
explaining us this is stupid I feel
embarrassed even saying this but I was
golfing this this is Brian's story yes I
was golfing you Tom and all for this Pro
you're a golf for the pro I sure haven't
Brian you know the thing is is a few
pointers and listen it's different than
boxing it's more of like a hobby so once
you see how it's done you can basically
do it so hardest work so golf yeah I'm
so yeah guys yeah like pros man so each
Oh gives me a few tips I hit 330 yards
he looks at me goes you doing the pro
tour and I what you think is you're in
tune with your body I went wow man Wow
and we went on our day and then I went
yeah I'm not gonna touch that I'm gonna
let Brian asking me you you were very
very charitable you're now you're
athletic
I'm get you did you I'm gay I'm gay
about it I can be a little harsh I come
off a little harsh sometimes
wow man like yesterday I feel I feel
like apologize even the lady at the
front door she goes oh yeah what are you
doing here on a Tuesday and I was on the
phone I went what she was what are you
doing on a Tuesday but I was busy on it
it's just the way I come on sometimes I
go I'm here every Tuesday every Tuesday
I'm here I do my own show so Monday's
fine kid Wednesday's find the kid
Tuesday I'm here every Tuesday she goes
okay I went come on I hit the elevator
and I'm like oh my god what the [ __ ] is
wrong yeah I feel like apologizing I
love it because because yeah and I
should have surprised she's like deserve
it but I probably deserve her because
the so cuz now I'm thinking about me
being a superior athlete as a golfer so
she says I said I I go I played golf I
had a good time said this to her I got
plague of my dad and I was fun actually
was hitting the ball well you know and I
go up you know the thing is and I said
this to her
the thing is this is my nanny I don't
even know where I go the thing is I I've
been using my body in an athletic way
for so long already how my body would
pretty much do anything I tell it to so
oh when you say stuff like that do you
feel sick no because nobody else is
listening and I enjoy being like Matt
Mitrione ever said I'm 50 you ever say
something than like God my friends were
around right well I would be I did I did
Barry Katz's podcast and I started
talking about how I was very cats is a
really big manager and he has a podcast
he's had patty Jenkins said all kinds of
big people on it and he he I started
talking about fighting because he said
you're in shape and I was talking about
how in life there are moments where
there's no left or right turn to fight
and I brought it now I wanted to stop
her second I'd do a podcast with a real
fighter Brendan Schaub who was top 10
UFC heavyweight if he heard me right now
he would be he'd have to pick a spot to
stare out on the wall cause he'd be so
embarrassed so at least I'm admitting
that last night come restore a great
time by the way Tony Hinchcliffe last
tour date like on this he's been an
awesome Nationwide Tour so he has all
his friends on their jermiah what doctor
why he plays this subject yeah now he
did all stand up so he just does sax on
Tony but just regular stand up there's
Rogan there's Sam Tripoli so we're all
in the back and fun time and Jimmy Carr
comes you know that is true the English
comic I performed with the Massaro you
know I know who he is incoming he's in a
suit and he's in the back he's
introducing stuff anyone as a kid to see
he's talking about how there's there's
no hanging in London in the comedy scene
in London we should have Mercedes up
such a beat yeah let's get him on I love
him so I've never met him but I see you
know who he is being around the come
comic scene and I'm like ah [ __ ] this
Jimmy Carter you know I'm half English
my mom I've seen no serious so much man
my mom would [ __ ] freak out if she
knew I was with this guy right now I'm
thinking about that and he's going
around there and he's a great improviser
and you can tell he's like he's hot this
guy who's this guy was back there taking
pictures documenting everything took
brilliant pictures I forget his name
sorry dude
brilliant picture taker B has an old
camera
and he goes he starts roasting them he
goes we're what lab do you get those
developed in he just roast and I'm dying
laughing so funny and then I mean I've
never met him we no one introduced us
and then he just goes and looked at me
I'm like oh [ __ ] now I got those Gucci
loafers on with Tigers on them
oh boy and he goes before I continue it
was these accent he looked at ruinous
before make fun of his shoes what am i
dealing with here here's one mating
here's your comic right and I go yeah
guys I've seen you on the pictures tear
and stuff like that your big guy though
what are you doing bro and goes ah I
wouldn't make fun of those shoes too
much and he was why not and he goes well
he was a top contender than heavyweight
Davinia's are you [ __ ] me and he was
thing is he probably didn't know he was
like mmm before I make funny looks it
rolling and then he was like no cuz he
didn't know and he's pointing to me and
wrongness he's asking antonio's who'd
win he was get both those guys are built
who would win in a fight he start my you
and Rogi he has no idea well he doesn't
know and that's it until we put out my
shoes I was like ah it was so funny man
yeah it was so funny that cracks me up I
was in the knee I was telling my house
in London and I was like yeah everyone
dressed is so nice out there man like I
wish you'd wear a suit like you all the
time I'd look like an [ __ ] doing
stand-up in suit because yeah you would
you would and then he go and then he's
like those are Gucci's he's like I like
what Gucci's doing right now I'm like
right give it up because they're Gucci's
killing right now if you're in a fashion
like on the for Claire care the biggest
in the world is everyone's copying them
they're actually suing these big
companies couldn't stop him I will write
I would give me some and gives me that
means yeah it's like a North Korean
pimps they're designer and just starts
clown and my shoe city before I was like
he's [ __ ] oh he's all he's sleeping
as special enough we know we both did a
couple of improv shows it in Montreal so
we're on the same ticket it was just a
small group and I gotta tell you I
watched him and he can [ __ ] him put it
down that guy is as good as it gets
7 million followers I Pacific what was
in a suit always inside the home
wishing he was a per you know but
probably had dark [ __ ] in a good
way
yeah and then he was saying that I go oh
what are you doing out here you live on
hangers no I'm out here taking meetings
on TV shows I'll never again go back to
London and Tony goes he lives in a
castle okay yeah he's losing a castle
you just color I was making that kind of
money I don't know again and then you
always want to do what you're not doing
I don't know one comedian who doesn't
want to be acting really yeah Rogan yes
[Laughter]
he goes you know what I was into this
audition and they asked me to do it a
different way and I looked at the
director and I went now the guy goes
excuse me cuz I'm not doing it that way
I don't feel like it and he goes if you
want to hire me we can do it on the step
and I'm not doing it here in this room
God last night before I went out to do
my set if we're talking about natural
disasters and their time at the
Hurricanes and then same tripolis talked
about the earthquakes and then rolling
start talking about the fires and I was
like I'm so stressed out right now yeah
I do not want to talk it was I mean just
the idea that there's so much going on
just everything well there's a hurricane
apparently so fabbrizio has two
restaurants in st. Barts please [ __ ]
yeah and and and this is apparently the
biggest hurricane second-biggest ever
right no but this is they say this
hurricane Irma Irma is the biggest
hurricane in the Atlantic that the
Atlantic Ocean has ever seen and he was
showing me live pictures of st. Barths
because he's got cameras outside his
places and the [ __ ] palm trees were
literally like yeah everybody had to be
in under 25 with no windows 125 yeah 175
miles an hour from what I read really
certain parts 175 mile they're getting
the worst down there and then to Macon
Republic right yeah Florida and the
Miami's gonna get crushed no joke man
look at that live updates it's so scary
man yeah it is when when when Mother
Nature is like
it just keeps blowing there's nothing
you do now and they were saying like the
the structures down there it's not you
know Houston got hit hard but they have
you know its first world countries yeah
like the structures are pretty [ __ ]
good right there's a little difference a
little different well you know oh you
got a house made of bamboo yeah yeah see
yeah apparently you can't build a
structure to withstand like a stage five
a cyclone like a tornado a tornado
weekend if it turn it hit your house I
guess there's no way I thought either
yeah underground we'll see Matt though
there's a cement ones you can build that
don't leave the ground yeah stay in the
ground but it has to be built under it
has to be like chained to that like you
know yeah some [ __ ]
I guess otherwise you know when out in
Denver we used to have the tornado
warnings and my dad like let's get you
and you could go outside and see it like
well you know chin down looks like you
were safe in your car you're not lock
all right and throw a car idiot thinks
you saved my car I'd be like anyway my
car in Denver my dad makes feel the
basement I mean there was so much fun
because it was like playing camp out
with your dad your brother in the
basement we just been waiting - yeah
[ __ ] in it's so crazy but hurricanes
natural disasters are [ __ ] tidal
waves to a tsunami the quakes out here
yeah earthquakes I seen although the
ground can open up and and swallow you
there's plates of trouble yeah an
earthquake I mean the ground you could
theoretically and you could die by
getting swallowed by the ground that
could happen you you could die that way
like that's what you're like what cases
[ __ ] scary yeah tsunami horrible I
don't know I feel like tsunami you just
drown yeah you're getting [ __ ] up bro
you're getting [ __ ] that's a giant
thing notes it's smashing your body into
the building yes and then you're just
you you got a ball up your swim yeah
ride the wave bro right no sir [ __ ]
no you're right no I don't know I don't
you know we had some trouble yeah don't
you dive into the wave not when is that
big it's still under it doesn't matter
there's nowhere to go
it's just stressing me out land by the
way everybody I read a dropping
knowledge 28 that there are not 28
amendments
Thank You chase for emailing me and
telling me that chase thanks you guys
world you know me emails and there no 28
and by the way the thank you for the
hurricane thing but but it still stands
that the idea that hurricanes are
actually more intense is still not
supported however is somewhat warming
yes somewhat but but is global warming
caused by man or by I would imagine that
the bulk of the science says it's caused
its anthropomorphic which means it's
caused by humans partially caused at
least by human being yeah we're not even
active we're not hoping it I know that
it's better to err on the side of
caution anyway say it say that we even
if we don't know isn't it better to like
kind of you know not keep [ __ ]
putting greenhouse gases into the
atmosphere just in case like you know I
don't know man it's that's the other
thing cooling the planet I don't know I
don't say about that how are we gonna do
that what you cool these nuts in your
mouth I'm not gonna do that desk cuz
that's how you always use global warming
to get me stuck that's how you give me
the circuit Wow Terran Kelly and look
it's just a lot better-looking than your
Norwegian dude your voices texted you
don't have to sing that okay this is the
coolest office you know what a nerd I am
I just pop past like three offices with
video games I just said that you're a
nerd because you he has a room full of
star is it star wars there's some of
that yeah what else do you dominantly
star wars but it's it starts with all
the toys that I collected as a kid right
there's a lot of x-men a lot of you
could be with the same age though so
it's like x-men Teenage Mutant Ninja
Turtles exactly right else yeah anime
knows the big two he mana
at one point but I don't really judge
more got it he-man
Thundercats were big Voltron was BAE
correct and the new Voltron series on
Netflix is very good you because it
doesn't just dropped please drop just
drop who is your favorite superhero I
was a big spider-man guy really yeah cuz
I was very small growing up I was very
little
not anymore my team just freakin Nordic
in stature you are big too just you have
a great body
organizers heard of the 13th century
Nordic stature beard though - huh yeah
beard and you never seen you with a
beard I don't hold on you skipped over
that better bid than 100% things are
thicker stronger fuller beard I told
Brian owner browner wait wait less gray
Brian show up the comic store that day
for everyone
whoa what are you doing coming here
without dying your beard run Oh dad I
was sent back I was sent back to the
drawing board had to that's wrong it had
to dye it up a little bit yeah will shoe
polish through the beard that's right
why do you have what happened you
shooting up again yeah cold in here I
just had the first general physical I've
had and I think five or six years you
know what it was bad I can always just
scary because yeah I had my physical and
I was a little high in the old
cholesterol I expected me Jim I expect
like I had my blood done and my I never
this was six years ago five years ago
and he goes dr. Horowitz goes well how
do I put this
your blood work is pretty much
outstanding and that was all he said
feels good and then I went last year or
less than that six months ago and he
goes there's some abnormalities in your
blood and I was like let's help get you
because your cholesterol your probably
high your cholesterol it was it's a skin
cholesterol is a myth here's a
prescription climate change climate or
myth both myths by liberals
dry land is not a myth hi [ __ ] Liv
you remember anything from Waterworld do
I ever
alright good good interview buddy thank
you thank you for having me bye Oh
[Music]
that's the podcast you dad
closed our office huh this is amazing is
this where you've always done it
mothership right here this is awesome
well Brennan Brennan is the guy who runs
the business so what a Brennan he'll do
is he'll go I'm gonna we needed a new
studio and then I go what do you want me
to do and he goes nothing and then I
just show up great then he gets an
artist to draw this stuff he buys all
the furniture on Amazon and then I'll go
should we do this he goes shut up and
then I just show up and I show up okay
great then I go
what about hiring he was shut up yeah
guess he gets chin have you met chin
Taryn it's rescued me from the elevator
sale yes I'm like a real shitty version
of Lauren Michaels for podcasting yes
great oh no it's all good yeah no that's
that I already you're much more
personable so I think I've spoken to you
more now and having just really that no
not really no I he's an interesting guy
yeah he's it's he's an eccentric right
yeah now now yeah I have my own take on
him because I saw I saw the good you
know what I mean incredibly generous
incredibly loyal there are people who
have worked on that show like on the
behind-the-scenes side there are people
who've been there since 77 75 yeah yeah
say yeah Eugene Lee who's the scenic
designer does a ton of like did wicked
and he does like huge Broadway shows has
been the scenic designer for now the
entire run yeah yeah it's amazing and I
went to he invited me to see play with
him and his sons when it so there were
there were good moments and then and
then I you know the complexity in
frustration or or or questions come out
of how how quickly that turns how fast
the winds change this thing yeah
probably I said III think it's fair to
presume yeah cuz he's very good at
business
I mean there is no greater comedic
institution in the history of
non-western culture
really you know yeah yeah and it's and
it's fascinating in it and it defines
him and it is his first love yeah it is
very clearly what he what is what he
thinks about what he what he worries
about what he stresses about and how
much of a say does he have on this
sketch is like everything everything
yeah so you come on the sketch and yeah
he goes yes now yes and he has a clearly
has a crystal clear sense of humor he to
an extent yeah and I would I would give
him credit in that I think he has his
sensibilities and he knows what he finds
funny but does his best to remain open
to you know there are different flavors
of ice cream for a reason cuz you know
it's gonna work - yeah yeah there are
different styles yeah there are
different sensibilities and different
demos of the audience who are watching
in a way he's already right
I would imagine just because it's like
hey dude yet you how do you like the
scoreboard as a new I think you're wrong
I've got some ideas on how to change
your 42 year old show get out see you my
boy his scoreboard score would yeah
without a doubt
and and and but you were there for six
years yeah and you were a standout your
act there is a bias I mean Brian knows
as I I'm obsessed with saying that live
like watch since I was a kid it's I mean
my mom and I were every Saturday man
I've never missed in a long long time I
read the book I've got seen all the dot
it Lorne Michaels all that stuff yeah
and I'm always interested in like
everyone taught everyone from I mean
Marc Maron talks about Steve Martin
talked about the interview process I
find it so like there's a Hard Knocks
right for the NFL and it shows like guys
getting cut I wish there's a Hard Knocks
force a night life yeah just to think of
me people have tried out for it and I
just for it crazy names yeah people like
what you never had well for me just when
I remember you said to me I'm I said
what are you up to I haven't talked to
you in you go I'm basically working 24/7
at The Groundlings because I want to be
on SNL mm-hmm and you were going through
their program and I didn't know what you
meant
then I went to your graduation yeah
and I think I told you this but I I was
so blown away by the level of work you
guys were doing especially yours like
this sketch you wrote that weird sketch
with the wood you were in like some
Schreyer do remember it was so [ __ ]
genius and weird I was like I don't like
the turn right this but long story short
I remember the amount of work that went
into just getting ready like just
developing characters just being passed
by growlings ever since then I've always
said the new actors they come to LA I go
you want to be an actor you want to
learn characters you want to work go to
The Groundlings and try to get through
that because that's it's supposed to
boot camp so how's that and then you get
to SNL did was that the plan or did did
Pete sewing Doyle you got a start here
to get to they're like I know I came
into comedy a little bit backwards I was
a freshman at UCLA and I was actually
going for musical theater that's I was a
musical theater major and so like
singing and dancing and shop and bow as
always and he had a boyfriend that and I
and I was a lover it's cool it's cool
you're married now just an artist sure
sure
you know he worked a lot with clay just
thing just Roman he's strong but soft
lumberjack and just very flexible just
just amazing with angles with just a
real ham angular digits angular
phalanges why are you looking at me so
hard real I'm just yes handing your bid
your eyes are so hypnotic right sorry
sometimes they're blue sometimes they're
green I was mimic I was a goof and I got
an audition for MADtv that I kind of as
a fluke it just it just snowballed and I
got the job at 19 years old and no
training no stand-up no sketch improv
and a lot of the riders there and
performers who I really respected and
and who looked out for me and were good
people but obviously the funniest in my
opinion had come from Groundlings then
and I had a buddy who was already in the
school Mikey de who's now on SNL he was
already going working his way through
the through the training so when I left
MADtv I just went back and said I really
like doing this but I want to get better
at it
and from that day on SNL was sort of
like the singular focus the goal and
then when you're there at Groundlings
then how do you make the transition to
get that audition Saturday Night Live I
do an agency they don't know so you know
that it's rent that some of it is just
circumstantial some of its just gonna be
timing and luck but I always kind of had
the feeling that if I could get in front
of law if I could get the audition I
would have a decent chance just because
of my skill set and sure that I could do
and and you just spend your time there
and it was six years it was six years
from my very first basic class to
performing in Sunday company and Lorne
Michaels came to a show they were
looking for people and I and I know at
the time they're specifically coming to
look at the seam who ended up getting
the show but he flew a bunch of us out
he flew me and three others in the seam
included Nasim got at that year she and
I had to audition twice on the stage
it's the hardest audition she's going
there right wait five hours six hours I
would say it's it's head games
intentional and not if you've been in
the space have you been to 8h I have not
it's great you got to go it's it's so
fascinated sits it feels like church you
know and it feels like a holy place just
especially if you love the show because
it's it's deceptively small once it once
the show's going on and I think seeing
SNL live is the best way to appreciate
it because you're seeing the show within
the show which is the commercial breaks
dropping sets there you sit above
exactly yeah yeah it's a but it's it's
small it's teeny except for when it's
literally just you on home base which is
what they call the stage where the
monologue happens that's also where
Weekend Update happens it's just you
empty dark except for a spotlight a
folding table of like eight people or
producers and writers and how much time
do you have up that they say five
minutes they say five minutes and try to
do three impressions three original
characters and people do all kinds of
variations what did you do I did - the
first time I did two original characters
and like 12 impression
and then the second time which was only
three weeks later they said they want
all new stuff was another nine
impressions and like three characters
what were the characters the first time
around I'm an old lady yeah yeah it was
this is called characters this is
octopus yeah let me give you a massage
gross with a secret I have a secret
[Laughter]
that's just the guy behind it if he's
telling us you do all those and then did
you know how to how soon after once you
so what is the audition guy day I had
like you know like the test they call it
tested one test three weeks later a
second test for the same year and didn't
get it and then heartbreaking you or no
no cuz the first the first audition
you're like I did it I'm here that like
the the SNL people saw me cuz like you
said you know Carell and Jim Carrey and
you know all these people who have
auditioned that show and didn't get it
but went on to amazing incredible things
it is this amazing validation and if
you're a fan of the show which I was my
entire life same as you getting to be in
that space getting invited myself
I like had because there was four of us
going out there I had a limo greet us at
the at the airport and like made a mix
CD CDs were still a technology that
existed then and like Frank Sinatra's
New York New York was blaring as we were
going through love through Lincoln you
got it or like just showing up going on
station and just like went out that
night and just like soaked it in because
no matter what win or lose I was good
enough you know yeah and then the second
audition was really in my head because
now it's like oh they like something
they're bringing me back this could
happen that and that was a level of
stress and I and I think it affected my
audition for me yeah and what we were
told is it's no but not never and he's
definitely on our radar and we're
keeping him in the mix and I took that
with a grain of salt because I think
whatever whatever but but then also took
the discipline of if that opportunity
arises I'm going to be prepared so we
went back to Sunday company had a whole
year of doing Sunday company and then
being environment company is what there
is is the growling yeah yeah the jr.
that you the Sunday performace new show
every Sunday they're pitching sketches
every week it's really amazing show
today we got to go see the school it's
such a great show yeah it is like the
freshest the hungriest sketch comedy you
know such talent there man
Groundlings is amazing because it is is
a like really tough process and and they
kill a lot of darlings along the way
really funny people that I performed
with her or don't get to - I know I
remember seeing everybody in your
graduating ass everybody and I think
that was the that was sort of the
there's a solutions yeah yes didn't make
it astonishing dude I mean I was like
what the [ __ ] it was unbelievable what's
her name though who writes on SNL now we
I had Jillian Bell Joyce now yeah
Jillian arias wrote for a year and you
know now is starring in movies yeah
she's killing her own show which is
hilarious she's funniest person I've
ever met um Sarah Baker another one
who's hilarious she's seen her and a
million different things
Dana Powell my buddy Nick Vanessa like
it was everybody you meet at that point
so talented so talented has really
really has something to offer so then
you're there for a year and then the
opportunity rises again yeah and and
third time was a charm so I so same
thing audition all new material all
stuff I've been working on with you know
that audition in mind did the audition
and you just stand up there cuz I know
with MADtv you just go you got five
minutes you just stand up there now just
go from Kara but you had I feel like
you're the big advance because you've
been there twice
yeah that's go back work on your craft
yeah then come back so I'm sure the
other people that audition I also had
the experience but I you know when you
know the field actually and I help man
exactly knows game time at that point it
was very much like focus do your thing
don't psych yourself out but also don't
you know just you're there don't you
yeah so then you do that and then did
you know right after you got the gate no
then then like another week and a half
and they say they want you to meet with
Lauren they want to fly you out and have
a meeting with and this is where you sit
in his office yeah it's what everyone
talks about yeah you show up and there
was waiting but it wasn't as bad as I've
heard it can be they brought us into the
talent office and I was sitting there
and there's like another person who
would audition is a girl jet was sitting
there and the talent departments meeting
and they bring in Tom broker who's one
of the had designers there who you know
weighs in on all aspects of the show and
it's just is this person crazy is this
person hostile is this because I think
they've already started to form their
opinions and ideas of who they're gonna
hire yeah
but they you know that year they brought
maybe six or seven people in there three
so so so on the people that met with lon
yeah not everybody job yeah so that's
the final mark Maret Marc Maron explains
that where he got to that point yeah and
yeah he go he's off Cena said Lauren
goes do you want some candy he's all
sure it takes a candy and goes right
when I put in my mouth I knew I [ __ ]
because I think they were toying with me
see I disagree I think Lauren just wants
to see you at ease yeah and as a
respectful human being but
nor can his head was that cone Oh Delvin
he's like you know I walk down I walk in
there and you say you know whatever you
think you're doing south of Houston
yeah isn't real comedy you know it's
supercharged
and but he's made peace I we saw mark
when he came in because he came in for
two nights to interview Lauren in his
office so we saw that's right Vanessa
and I were like hey did happen you
haven't talked to Lauren since you left
right all right no we cross paths at
like a screening a month afterwards you
know the thing I'm always curious about
is what's the contra and you don't have
to give certain exact numbers but what's
the contract looked like do you sign
like a million dollars in episode I
don't know that's that good I don't have
about numbers I care about like the
fourth model money I don't think you
made up like four hundred million
dollars on that pretty sure no I
definitely four hundred a month the
number it was four hundred an episode oh
wow your ground
no here you're like guys you signed like
a year deal and there's a person seven
years seven year countries similar to
like testing for a pilot where they'll
send you to five I think for a pilot SNL
used to be five and learned their lesson
signed you up
yeah it's smart you are now you just
directed Arnold Schwarzenegger yes in
the movie what's it called killing
Gunther killing Gunther yeah I'd like to
watch the trailer with you know great I
want to get anyway all right yeah and I
so you're a bit precocious because you
you go get what you Hamilton yeah so you
say Kings drop to us I live then you
start doing Hamilton you start doing all
this stuff yes with for you when Senate
live was a K we're all good here did you
look at like us an opportunity were you
super bummed that opposed both
truly it was it was it was as
complicated as those things can get and
that they'd asked for an extension right
and it's a thing that they do
occasionally with people in the cast
that happened - they did it to Jay they
did it to Vanessa they do it to people
to mess with that I think they did it to
Nasim I know that happened to forte
where July 16th they have
let you know contractually you're coming
back next year or not and occasionally
they'll go we need an extension because
we haven't made up our minds Thanks yeah
and I just saw what it did to my friends
and and it doesn't make you feel good or
wanted or excited or no good about
yourself and that last year was a little
different because what they were saying
is we just need two weeks because we're
doing this to everybody and I don't know
if that was true or not but I was like
no I'm literally on set about to shoot
like you know a gun fight and the filing
cabinet explodes and they call me like
they need two weeks and I'm like you
know what no I can't I only have one
more in me because that's what you
signed for you son for seven I have a
family I have a wife I have kids harf
you do because mobilising Kobe was doing
so he's married to Cobie Smulders and
Kobe was where was she she was in LA for
the first four years they were still
doing how I Met Your Mother
so I was flying back and forth about
that every two to three weeks I was
flying from New York telling people
realize the schedule as now because you
guys are working all night Monday yeah
Monday Saturday yeah yeah Monday to
Sunday you know it's exhausting so when
they're like hey we need to extension I
know I need to know now I need you know
I I'm not in a place where I'm looking
to extend you know where you don't and
they said at that point we had to get
post the post scheduled for this film
approved so that was gonna take me into
October November so you're already
working on another project while you're
waiting for this yes and then and then
Showtime had offered me this pilot with
some great people Jason Katims and Stu's
Dickerman and written it and I liked it
and it seemed like a really nice project
and it wasn't going to interfere with
SNL but we hadn't brought it up to them
so we said okay let's go back and say
approve this ok the pilot and we'll give
you the two weeks and they did and then
three weeks later something they called
me suddenly how they've decided they're
not gonna pick up your contract show
noise okay you got me guys okay youyou
decided okay great yeah yeah so then I
telling him and and everybody mostly was
very nice but there was no no call from
Lauren there was
six years no no call nothing no no phone
call no thank you no nothing and like
I've heard stories similar and then like
my opening night on Hamilton he sends
like two dozen roses you know and I mean
it's it's a it's a it's a so calm
strange very odd it's very odd it's when
you met with him for that final energy
ow
what did he say to you it was super
casual I walked in he was wearing like a
like a short sleeve polo padding a
Pernod like yeah exactly
he just removed his eye patch no he was
texting with his son and he's like come
on [ __ ] bro I'm just texting with my 18
year old and I was like yeah I hear
that's the best way to communicate with
him these days he's like your audition
was very strong the dealer - were strong
but this one was very precise I was like
oh thanks yeah I mean I certainly worked
on it and and didn't and and he has
these stories colloquialisms that he'll
repeat you know I mean he's got like you
know this shows the closest thing to
being in professional sports you know
there were year there's new players and
you're only as good as your last game
and the audience has to own you they
have to take ownership of you have to be
rooting for you and you've got to stay
in shape you know it's it's do you have
98 mile an hour fastball or do you have
a 77 mile an hour fastball that's the
difference okay I know exactly what you
were meaning and what is it what is it
what is broke with his mouth is himself
an aristocrat [ __ ] is he don't know
fan of William F Buckley I have I have
this theory that and and and it's and
it's not like with judgment but I do
think he's a bit of an addict hmm I
think he's an addict to success an
addict isset to fame I think you'd have
to at this point and I noticed a shift
at the 40th where he's literally
surrounded by his best friends Jack
Nicholson and Paul McCartney and these
people who at one point he idolized and
was a fan of a busy but together as
equals there's peers
he's seen the rise of Belushi Aykroyd
Meyers he's a wig Farrell you know he's
he's been on the ride so many times
that too he's a piece of history miss
American cultural has no doubt and a no
driver of American coffee yes without a
doubt it'd be tough not to time to be
addicted to that right yeah you know
what I heard I'm rush of fame success
overnight you know what I mean and so I
also feel that there's a little less
patience maybe than there it's a
blessing and a curse
yeah most I had an interesting
conversation with somebody who knows him
very well and you'd know him and has
spent time with him you know on vacation
and him and some of the other of his
other very wealthy powerful friends
mm-hmm and what was very interesting as
they were saying that the one thing all
of them as they get into their 60s are
obsessed with what do you think it is
tennis notoriety no health mortality how
interesting yeah they've got everything
that you can imagine the only thing they
don't have is immortality the only thing
they don't have is that really good
surgery they're not gonna die right
their attention start talking about
something that you can measure that
actually will extend your life or any
and they all go root and they're just
like my friend my face two tops are
struggling the plot of death because
when you've done everything you have
everything the mystery of so much that
kind of breaks down yeah but they also
are loving their life for there's a lot
to live for and so when you start
talking about you know you can live an
extra ten years they'll be like what you
know that's the one thing they can't cuz
they I just got this boxes of nanobots
in the mail Oh strange nanobots into
your bloodstream and they can they fix
any abnormalities problem is they're
kind of expensive it's not a problem
so then you link up with Arnold
Schwarzenegger start directing a movie
yeah did you write this you wrote yeah I
wrote this - yeah you wrote this my
wrote it I'm in it and I directed it and
yeah yeah that's a big when you when
you're writing it you have Arnold in
mind no and I should have and it's the
I'm such a fool because I literally
named the character Gunther and didn't
but because it was it was inconceivable
that our old Schwarzenegger would waste
his time on this like low-budget comedy
mockumentary like I want I wanted to do
Christopher guest's Eugene Levy movie
that's an action movie that's all I
wanted to do and and and so what I did
try to do what I sense I swung for was
to stunt cast a villain who comes in at
the end you know big reveal hidden my
mind would be a secret until the movie
comes out and maybe was somebody I
worked with at SNL because they they
could put a face to the name and they'd
be like oh I had a good time with him I
trust Aaron I'll show up for a week
yeah week and a half and do this fun
thing a favor and and and Arnold's reps
were like he's looking to do something
like this he's looking would you
consider it I was like yeah literally
like my favorite movie star from the
moment I couldn't remember you know I
got a laptop because of term an awesome
awesome see I got a flat top because of
Batman forever but but no he does the
best Joker but he won't do it know know
what I mean to do it really like I stood
the room in a depressing way is the best
Joker everything yeah he does this laugh
and I had him do it in front of all like
our friends yeah he was like a Gil night
like mid running charades like it's a
running charade lemonade he does it and
I swear to God I believe this it was
everybody's like hook anyway he goes
have he went I just heard you go it was
dead silent way you went well
okay because it's full commitment to
before dark night comes out and the
posters out people are seeing the heat
legend making Latvia and and like we're
just shooting the [ __ ] at Brian's house
and we're like how do you think he got
the scars and I like I'll tell you
exactly how I got my cut it he's like he
lost a bet he's like a bet and he and
he's like we're gonna kill you or
whatever and he goes no no please please
and they like murder his wife in front
of him he takes them they go like now
you kill yourself you know or you can
cut your know and it hurts from
hysterical sobbing and crying into
maniacal laughter and I was all doing
okay all right I'll do all do like 80%
of okay so should we switch running for
a TV dude he did that another yeah in
the whole room after he kills in the
whole room no rooms all how good is that
though like song that's like mostly
we're like oh there's a new Batman movie
like what care your reaction at that you
go and that all that here and your eyes
are bloodshot you go well it was
different with it was different
I had this go different I don't know I
forgot a line they would explain your up
Janine you stupid [ __ ] my list
you could play The Joker you'd be great
all those that's a [ __ ] good audition
for Todd Phillips I think is doing a
movie with the young Joe yeah he's
trying to get decay I sent a video
learnt repository hence with audition
for Todd on my phone I send it to todd
todd
like I'm in Mexico who's the nerd will
sasso who's one of your favorite and one
of your biggest fans
he sent me I think I just wanted to read
this I thought you get a chat I got this
out of the blue he goes hey what do you
do for a chap trunk
I go what chapter I Chapter trunk as in
my deck he goes what's good for that is
there some kind of salad or just spit
what's the deal I go bro I don't know
I'm not comfortable with this you guys I
mean my uncut hog I go yeah I know he
goes it's chapped and that's that was
the threat thanks a lot anyway it may be
I know we loved you and he was like a
lifesaver to me in MADtv like 19 no
you're on there with ya you know it's
the year that Tenacious D came out so we
would like sit in his dressing room
and he'd play guitar and we'd sing songs
you know you know he said about you when
I we did How I Met Your Mother and I
first met you and you were so funny and
we just got along because I was like
this guy plays and you were so but you
were so much younger than me you were
like 24 and I was like he's so [ __ ]
yeah I said the well do you know Terran
kill him he's funny as [ __ ] and and will
goes oh he's a genius yeah he's a genius
he was a 19 where that's coming from a
jazz coming from [ __ ] genius will is yes
let's watch
killing Gunther the official trailer
great I can't wait the first 1.1 yeah
look at that bad a lot of views get
ready for those to blow up okay fighter
on the kid
günther maybe the most feared hitman
working in the industry today you wanna
be king you have to kill the king
[Laughter]
[Music]
my name is I need to find the window
[Laughter]
assassins trying to kill me I couldn't
miss pop in a bit of a rocky start I
want to kill him even more
earning way over our heads FBI I would
like to report yes well you're gonna try
to kill him again we got to be on our
toes
I can't wait to see come on do it
that looks great down the DISA Gosselin
it's so much fun he was such a good
sport I've never seen him play that kind
of character he looks like he's just got
this is like the cell and the spin that
I'll say about his performance in this
is that he hasn't been funny in a long
time right like the actual like earnest
attempt is maybe jingle all the way
through twins a little bit well twins
certainly twins Kindergarten Cop he's
done it but but the difference between
even those movies and this one is in
twins and Kindergarten Cop it's the joke
is it's him in an awkward situation like
he's so big I'm so strong and here he is
inciting the human right he's the one
screwing with us he's the one being
fight it's the penny so punish him here
I'm adding that fake laugh it's him
dressed like that with the classroom I
know yeah it's great arch look yeah nose
amazing it was so much fun it was so
surreal at every moment and just a
professional a gentleman on time I'm
rarely starstruck you know but I had yes
I was with John exam what we were doing
ride-along yeah and that goes on guys my
buddies coming to have dinner with us
and he just showed up and it was the
three of us in an empty Lobby hotel room
and I got to kind of talk to him for two
hours about politics yeah I would say I
was so blown away did you taste one
person okay did you suck like in the gun
club do you mind
did you suck like terminator I'm trying
to have a conversation why did you have
to say that okay so that was no sick of
it yeah
he's so used to it but I was I was and
then I saw him there and next I thought
we were friends and of course he did
it's all right
oh hey we're gonna watch the Pacquiao
fight the Bradley Packer what's up buddy
and yeah I saw him in Venice Beach right
Venice Beach he's like the goddamn
Venice Beach Muscle Beach I saw him with
a side yeah so I see him he's mr. Venice
besides my uncle I see him on his bike
with a fanny pack on his son and people
are behind them and I forget who I was
with the oh look at our with a fanny
pack on start making fun of miles like
the [ __ ] do you say yeah like that's one
guy that gets a clear path its warts me
out man it's like who else decided to be
the best at bodybuilding alone is very
hard
yeah very about to be this yeah the best
to this day then I move then the best
action movie star maybe ever
yeah right yeah him her the rock you and
then the governor to run a state like
now let's be real yeah crazy is that a
dream big kid it's and if you would have
said that Mike you're [ __ ] crazy yeah
no way I don't know if I've ever said
this on air but one of the things that
was interesting in the conversation was
he said they wanted me to do this movie
you know and I had the play a guy who as
a Spanish you know he has a whole
situation with his nanny was Spanish he
said this he goes but my scandal came
out so you know I go what are you doing
that situation but just lay low just lay
low
that's all he said I was like okay
moving on he was so he was so open about
you know when I when I was at a Muscle &
Fitness like red carpet event and he was
there and he was taking pictures with
everyone but he wouldn't take a picture
alone with it just a girl cuz I was
saying that I talked my buddies to mean
even shot a conversation I was go call
you know and then I'm back talking to
friut who it was and girls like can I
get a picture
he's I can he grabs and goes big man and
I'm like I think I'm good man he's like
Nunda ain't God I'm like what were we
doing and his a system of the kid won't
take pictures single with their girls so
yeah because yes sir you know they can
make it all look here's a picture
anything yeah smart boy yeah yeah I got
hammered kept going come on
come on kill me now come on do it do it
any kick Melo so you spent how long then
I had 13 days he was up in Vancouver
with us yeah and then such a dream a
fair amount since yeah do you enjoy
directing or acting but I do uh I I took
to directing very well but I I didn't
start this project thinking I would
direct um but I've learned many things
to this process but people are not not
as willing to pony up money for a niche
mockumentary in action film even with
Arnold yeah with Arnold yeah well I mean
Arnold did change the game but then it
becomes a different thing right so that
idea where I wanted it to be is he
reveals like before to get it yeah you
promote people know that he's in it and
and you know the budget balloons for
certain different aspects that you
hadn't considered before hand and and
the way it works with tears is that
every bump up in tear the crew is
getting a bump right because because the
Union penalties is like that so it
became a bigger thing than I had
expected but I'm glad it did because I
just learned that much more and that the
the substantial risk yeah I think really
forced me to focus and not and not dig
around as I maybe would under if I'm
like it's a throwaway movie with me my
friends I'm not maybe gonna take you
seriously this I'm storyboarding and
breaking down shots you know good shot
turn cast me in a musical yeah I sang I
sang and you saying I want to know what
love is I wanna know what love is and I
have to play that is you I want to know
man well I try to sing like foreigner
you realize how good that guy's voice is
like oh I can't come close to this I had
to play this guy I want to know what
smell fear is and come out with it this
dude you can get it Walter's beardy
September 22nd and then in theatres
October 20th dude that was nine years
ago cities
Stella wasn't even yeah yes holy [ __ ] I
know that's so crazy I know
I still remember coming I mean that
Joker stuff those game nights happened
at your Venice place on the walk damage
how much fun were though is so fun that
should remember all those old times and
talk about a choice cocaine cocaine and
dicks so you don't lunch
no how about when I whenever in here
like this Terran came over to work out
yeah like I want to work on I hope I
only have an hour I was like you're
gonna give me ten minutes we do a little
CrossFit yeah I think you threw up in
the alleyway
hun I'm gonna send my body rejected six
yes six minutes is good he Brian really
looked out for me and took good care I
had I had some guy last night at the
Comedy Store there's a bunch of us there
and this real skinny comic where I just
got done doing I said I come back and
goes dude I've been mean to ask you like
I'm just I'm just wire thin man
like what can I do and everyone's around
like waiting for me to answer you is
what can I do like I don't know man I
can eat right of protein I look down
steroids and true but everyone but I
didn't smile I went stewards yeah he
goes yeah right can you imagine go no
literally with your body type I do
steroids I'm like have a good night man
it opens like what's the [ __ ] are you
doing like how what do you want me what
we gonna break down i goddamn diet and
workout regimen yeah but probably like
high caloric lean proteins and muscle
mass building as you're right we know
the carbs they like that lady that's
lady night but I'm talking gum you want
8,000 pounds of their calories of
chicken raw chicken fava beans
this is broiled fava beans into a shake
it's exotic llama beans I see when they
asked me how to put our muscle you know
how do I get razor thin like you he
walks over me when we're parties he goes
I'm enormous he's like he's
self-conscious I'm a giant man right how
much is it genetics with you though
substantially yeah yeah yeah yeah he
said yeah he's strong among us your
friends amongst us also human being
marilla's gorilla
he's an owner he's am
as a heart yeah I'm like read if I if I
open up with him and everything I know
and you know I know a lot I'd have a
hard time I have I mean I would have to
meet him with everything full go for the
throat first yeah you know yeah yeah
punch through the neck
hey do with with him yeah yeah with your
movie coming out yes what like this day
and age it changes so much like what
would make it successful you know it's
like yeah just giving it completed
successful not save that sure else no
it's interesting because it's a
different distribution process I
wouldn't have known anyway but Saban
films who's our distributor has been
amazing they came on board before we
even shot anything it was called a
backstop deal they said we'll buy it we
want the rides up front and the way they
do things is they're trying to get more
into digital streaming and and putting
things out there so ultra VOD four for a
month before it's in theaters at an at
an escalated price you can rent the
movie you can't buy it to own right
where any tight UN's Amazon and so they
have it they have a shot-caller just
came out do you know that movie Nikolaj
coster-waldau doesn't movie that's
there's and there is they're very
excited cuz it was a big success and it
went ultra VOD when DoD movies from the
guy from Game of Thrones yeah yeah yeah
so that's what they're saying and then
it changes their theatrical strategy
because normally for a little boutique
select cities small budget film like
this you'd want a per screen average of
10,000 like that's Wow great we now we
need to go wider but because of the
streaming element of it depending on how
successful that is how many people will
download it there it lowers the
expectation for it where people have had
access to it for a month yeah so once it
comes out if it does three to five
thousand then play that's changing it is
the digital man everyone wants yes no
Netflix and Amazon and Hulu like you
want it narcos is out now and I'm
obsessed tonight you can watch the whole
series right in one shot sorry when
Arcos yeah yeah no [ __ ] yeah great
I'm just saying that that's not what the
usual
you can watch you can watch everything I
want child and I think of that see you
how did you remember your password Title
II is they show narcos changing after
like returning my three envelope I might
see my VHS wait for it to come out no
I'm saying but you know everything yeah
you can binge-watch your home movie yeah
you can binge them I won't watch if they
don't even break through but it would it
would change the dynamics cuz if I have
access to it at home I'm liking Cedars
right well or do you enjoy it so much
you want to take friends because it's
definitely and this will be the last
cell that I do on the program but it's a
great movie to see with a group of
friends in a crowded audience late at
night it's a fun but to your point that
they have to at least assume there's
give me some lower numbers because if
digital it kills it everyone just moves
amazing yeah but I've seen it
tone up see there's gonna be some sort
of downfall exactly said there's and
then there's also yeah you know the the
different generations the different way
people can what about this audience
Arnold Schwarzenegger in China is geek
gets his own thing blind you with it
blonde blind like with no like throw no
Bradley the Joyce brothers modest true G
one man he succeeded now your voice
juicier touched my lower lip skateboard
no but it's like this he's making money
doing that no he's giving you the money
Jews don't want it I don't want it in my
face or my mouth it's not to dad come on
today daddy takes the money juice from
the other daddy no drink down the money
juice from the other dad oh no your eyes
are you in a weird mood thing obviously
just learned about narcos he's not gonna
know that when there's two daddies
one daddy drinks down the money juice
from the other daddy
oh man you keep saying I don't want to
give my money to sit in water I want
daddy to have my money too
the movies called one daddy gives his
juice to the other it's a porno has
parentheses killing Gunther so that's
what are you doing after this now today
no with your Co the two day I'm about to
go shop a so as they say me and Bill
Lawrence yeah yeah we call them great
parents bill lawrence yeah who is very
good to me he cast me in a pilot launch
that led me to meeting my wife oh yeah
like alarms yeah me too what do I know
him so bill Lawrence did a little show
called scrubs Spin City before that huh
cougar town afterwards the large is a is
a six foot three inch handsomest [ __ ] it
turn on boy is handsome the [ __ ] like
like yeah a blue blood he looks he's a
very he looks like a an all-american
lacrosse player yeah yeah and oh by the
way he can also write on a high level
and yeah and create shows and his shows
go for like as long as he wants them to
Cougar Town yeah Spin City I mean yeah
yeah and a decent human being and a
great guy funny as [ __ ] and really cool
when you're in the room auditioning yes
yes yeah I love that guy yeah me too
he's married to Krista mm-hmm who are
again I knew Christa when she was an
actress and she was on that show it's so
you're pitching a show with him get a
picture show with him and then I'm
flying to Atlanta this afternoon I'll
start a Kevin Hart movie oh nice tell
Kevin Hart I daddy says hi oh well daddy
says okay daddy number two says I gotta
make a little video for keV daddy -
little Kevin video I might want to get
him on the podcast yeah that's what
we're gonna do
yeah you're gonna tell him to come on
the pockets go to the movie all right
all right it feels like it shouldn't be
my response Wiley but you just do it I'm
I'm I put you on this podcast you
promised me that you advanced
collaboratively I haven't he doesn't
know me any favors if anything no the
good faith is flowing in his direction
so if he asks something about and can I
use your white privilege okay anyway
that was my joke erby
the joker became the trigger so that's
it and then just move back to California
are you psyched in back very yeah New
York always felt temporary to me yeah I
know it did yeah yeah a little more time
together let's get out there I will say
like the second I could step off of
Manhattan and explore the surrounding
area
I LA I was like oh this is where I would
want to hang in stay like Connecticut is
beautiful New York in New York 24/7 is
exhausting Yamcha New York get liked
when we go there we do shows their live
shows they're just it's so much man I
mean green eyed oceans I name yeah same
just the space and I think it's just
whatever you're used to because the LA
versus New York culture of it all like
the the energy the people I call BS on
that a little bit I think that there's
both and you can find it where you're
looking exactly if there isn't as much
Jesus in New York and I think you
probably want to start talking about
Jesus okay that's why we bring in sure
okay that Mexican line mean he said you
fight like a Mexican meaning Mexicans
don't really move back or they'll come
straight in and fight you in a phone
booth that that's a macho way of
fighting right so they'll just come and
and he had his hands up and he kind of
walked McGregor down that would be a
Mexican style Wars it Boris
Floyd usually fights on his back foot
where he's very elusive that would be
considered I've heard boxing efficient
oh say that would be considered in the
Mexican culture to be that elusive to be
a little bit on macho a little bit
unmanly in fact yeah you can slip and
move around move away from my punches
but you're a [ __ ] I'm gonna stand in
front he's like a black guy being slow
okay yeah
isn't that true though I mean there's
that different yeah how cultures inform
your fighting style sure that's why it
was fascinating because I don't follow
or no or a magically she watched it but
we watched it there you go that's what's
the biggest of all time yeah
he's so entertaining they both are but
especially Connor your aunt's hat on I
do you're an actual fan recent Rams
season tickets live god bless you to the
to the home depot so we're at Coliseum
no Chargers are down on our side you
know I love football it's probably my
favorite sport and have been following
it since you know on my own since my
late teens and doing fantasy football in
LA hasn't had a team for so long that I
said the second we get a team again I'm
going all in and you're all in brown
little grabs two cokes we talk football
yeah yeah be part of this to what you do
not see I feel in in maybe it's just the
friends I have but God I'm growing you
to Leah no no one in the entertainment
really watch his foot I used to watch
football so much that I had the I
remember watching the new John Deere I
have exact TV football pack what
happened yeah I you know I was so
obsessed for probably 10 years I mean to
the point where Sunday's I'd never got
off the couch and kids I don't know what
happened man kids you want to know the
truth sure yeah [ __ ] about it but I
think once I started reading about the
head trauma
I know cuz I've known you for five or
six years you weren't into football then
it was around that and head trauma just
got slide like to use as I missed one
season I got busy I missed one season i
vacuumed went back but you've got in
your team did you're born in Clovis born
in Culver City out here local local kid
and I was really into the Raiders Marcus
Allen Bo Jackson well no the LA Raiders
in there LA I wish we got the Raiders in
the charges and rams kick rocks
generators are good yeah from there well
see I I mean the Rams that's pretty
rough right
last season was rough that corvex odd
office but he's not the answer I don't
think he is and I've heard from people
around the organization like it's just
in the woods just when hearing him talk
you know what I mean it's just doesn't
have the swag like oh really you know
it's that sort of like you think should
I I want to do what's good yeah that's
like you don't have it yeah yeah yeah no
it's tough it's tough to want I like
Mannion I think Mannion is sir
surely but it's rough but if they came
to LA and they started winning right
away no way you can call yourself a fake
because la is tough it's a tough sports
town to be a fan in you know what I
guess yeah and it's been heartbreaking
I've been I went to the two first
preseason games here maybe you're a big
fan you went to man he sees them doing
it yeah yeah I love it I love it I got
to bring my daughters to the last one
you know they couldn't hang the whole
game but I got to experience that and
just so cool being in that stadium is
beautiful I mean it's huge
close him yeah it's just huge open space
you know what those things hurt the RAM
arena the other thing that's gonna hurt
the Rams is they're not they're not
gonna be very good
they're just insert right SC and UCLA or
you know I have to study UCLA an SCS
4735 Z 35 points second please come back
that lazy and solar so when college is
killing its child if your pro team sucks
I think I mean and the Chargers it's
like I take it I make it about me and I
go like great great I like all I like
all these statistics I like these
circumstances cuz I can show I can
finally take ownership of the team I've
wanted for so long and if they win
immediately if they get if they don't
you know if you don't have your Cubs Red
Sox dry spell you know what I mean
you're not gonna feel that same
ownership in that same you shariah win
and if the winds start coming you know
you see what Phillip Rivers did know his
so he has seven or eight kids I think he
does and it's in North San Diego he
refused to move them to LA so he built
he had this giant car built he put 200 a
Legos yeah I goes here like you built it
out of like out of Legos these chains
why yeah he's gonna die he had $200,000
basically like first-class plane seats
in this in this car and it has a huge
spirit so it's they say it's can take
him an hour and a half to get to
practice yeah he's still getting in San
Diego but he can watch film on the way
so by the way they're in Carson you may
as well be in San Diego yeah where's
Carson exactly yeah
it's not la know yeah you ever bit did
you ever go to a galaxy game or anything
yes we actually flipped the coin that's
where it is yeah oh that's cool that's
all my brother-in-law who's a die-hard
soccer fan Swedish and had a full ride
of William Mary do you want soccer
player and and but if an M fanatic about
soccer and I said I'll get you on the
field
you might ever want to come down at
Galax game my brother-in-law goes I
really appreciate that but the level of
soccer that is played there is is hard
for me yeah yeah we bought season
tickets
the Beckham year that it wouldn't he
came in like the semi box yeah he goes
dude great yeah Dan suriname that's when
all the house crews getting us I don't
know pry when I'm older I'll probably
head over to LA get the big money and
just stand in the corner and watch the
ball go by I mean that's how it works
yeah like they take like the huge stars
over there yeah one on the back nine
like look it's Gerard what I'm like you
know what what a [ __ ] it's hard for
me to imagine a better like time than
being a European soccer star sure that's
gotta be a dish to play a lot they're
scheduled great non-stop you're rattling
don't play those ABS all right man
mm-hmm hon dude can you do current
events yeah yet going no I can do
current events let's do some progress a
10-count yeah I like this hard though
Casper sorry
thanks man don't piss like a donkey go
piss like this has been a disaster so
far I apologize I'm sorry to go I broke
your show way to go
yay huh human con you heard of it
January yay what do you got Jim well I
guess since you guys are making noise
about this Kim and Kanye's third baby is
due in January all right have you been
have you all have you met Connie uh I
did yes you spending time of them not a
ton no he's on SNL not you Ron and I
were on How I Met Your Mother I think
when Kim Kardashian was casting were you
there that day I don't know because she
did a guest star when I was doing it I
didn't remember I remember the Britney
Spears one that was a big deal
what do you mean Spears of guest star
for a week there oh maybe I was I've
done so much that I your mother yeah I
remember looking at her going as what B
I remember she was on the same episode I
was a honey yeah I remember looking at
her I didn't believe in wreckage I was
like I've seen it from the side and I
was like oh that's how long ago was he
last time I did was probably the last
episode I ever did a vest now I don't
know hi Ramona yeah I'm years ago was
that I don't know Jim look it out till
she was was she like Kim Kardashian then
yes so my dressing room is here and her
dresser was here and it said Kim
Kardashian if it pops up yeah 2009 whoa
it was a long time ago and was it that
big yet right just had to drop by here
to read this magazine I love - how long
is this Jim one minute a problem you
came all the way over here to read a
magazine I am willing to bet that there
is a place to read a magazine at work
you know a room with a little man those
acting is effortless
[Music]
you made a brave step today Elsa she
plays in a magazine shakes o heard she
was bold and goodness wow she's amazing
actor
you're great a super hot lady who my
wife keeps telling me why you're famous
but I keep forgetting let's do this so
they make fun over there right
small partner by the way mm-hmm what's
the current event channel actors all
right turn like of height I'm open six
foot I'm 64 yeah I'm also tall dude yeah
yeah well we said see we kind of set six
foot that's kind of the stage I don't
know I'm not a measuring the eyes I
don't have a measuring tape right now I
know I'm tall I I would buy what Santa
would not I don't know guys I'm not yeah
I'm what feel significantly less that's
why you keep trying to compete with me
in it no I don't need to that's
competitive till I'm just talking about
just from a pure objective stat
standpoint yeah I would see I'm not
looking I don't hey hey listen I'm
saying you were very kind to me you
looked out for me I learned a lot from
you yeah but now I've surpassed you see
philosophically and physically not you
that's not cool to say that you're on my
podcast that I own all right what is
this gym this at a beauty store
shoplifting so the cops caught her here
obviously and then when they put her
back in the patrol car she us somehow
wiggled her way outside of the handcuffs
she's a badass and they made her jump to
the front jumps to the front in this
county they don't have those plexiglass
windows up longer is this Wyoming you
some chances - taking her time get in
front them and then you see them she
must have wanted to really get the hell
out of there she did well that is
unfortunate
this is her viewing oh oh no no right
that's her
that would be scary yeah this is her
view this is what did she do she just
shoplifted at a beauty song she's like
what is the end game yeah this never
works out does it Mikey Spikers they try
they do get her I'd say she's gonna be
in big trouble here yeah so this is
and here it is right here oh she spins
out she spends on its flips yep yes Oh
didn't flip don't flip oh but in the end
they actually got her it's over
the cops are gonna treat you like shake
cuz that actually be embarrassed yeah
did you have to smash the window they
would have shot her if she started
driving his assault with a deadly weapon
dang that's a badass woman it is
impressive slip out of cuffs you steal
beauty supplies you know we out what did
she take I have no idea just get a
little supplies kind of my type I got
just a huge brass you know I'm saying
girl jars like that she had makeup on
yes
dang I brought my motorcycle out here I
was riding last night and I got up to 85
which like it's not that fast but you
feel your body work off of the bike it's
good I just crazy don't you get to don't
drive your motors Mickey Rourke he says
he's in talk with Golden Boy Promotions
about doing a boxing match that makes me
said at 60 64 and the guy he wants to
fight is 12 and 12 from Oklahoma well we
know the last one was staged huh so
check this out though so why all right
it seemed like it was staged he says
he's talking to the CSAC the
commissioner and the commissioner said
that because the last fight looked legit
he would greenlight this fight but so
tyranian was that it's such a [ __ ] show
his face is that was like right now he
looks different now that's I don't know
what that there are pictures where
Mickey looks certainly very I can't
recognize wearing a wig I don't know
whole thing is strange and this guy does
this guy look familiar to any any guys
yeah so uh do you remember a long time
ago the show called Jenny Jones and a
dude yeah there was like a secret crush
and then one of the secret crushes was
actually a guy and killed him
yeah and the wait what you don't know
this no so Jenny Jones was a TV host and
I think she was an actress comedian
yeah so she had a show which okay yeah
and they did secret crushes and then on
one secret crush this guy came in and
they're like yeah there's someone that's
what that wants to date you that's been
knowing you for a while
turns out it was a guy and this guy even
told the producers like if it's a guy I
don't want to be on the show they're
like no no no it's not turned out to be
a guy he ended up killing him because of
the embarrassment he had on the show
Zeus well he's out now how long was that
this is that was not mid-90s but not to
remember this man this guy's on parole
right now so he was so embarrassed
because it was a dude and he killed him
I Hilton that night the next day I think
yeah when you said the hotel show you
see him on the show he's like he's
acting all like he's like he's upset I
did it he was yeah well you couldn't
tell you subset you just could tell he
was like embarrassing kinda all guys and
then they I killed him holy yeah
damn and he got out got out and not that
long actually how much time did he do
who's good at math here when did he go
in 93 he's a 29 so 1014 yeah yeah 14
years a second-degree murder
term second-degree not first second why
is that I couldn't figure out either so
I guess he didn't want he didn't
premeditated for a long time it was
probably like he did the show he went
there
beat him up beat him to death by
accident or what I think he shot him oh
yeah pretty sure he shot ya when you
would get a gun and you shoot somebody
that's premeditated I don't know I don't
know maybe someone could actually look
into it but we don't yet moving on from
that you guys read this right the Boston
Red Sox used Apple watch I saw today on
the exam what's going on here so they
would have this kind of cheating right
yeah yeah so yeah I don't know much
about baseball but I do know when the
catcher does those signs underneath is
you know yes legs then you're not
supposed to see the other teams must
well see it so the other team had their
rest Red Sox staffers on the other side
or watching on a TV yeah find out what
the signals were and then go on their
iPhones all right there.i watches
whatever and then some Oh was it dugouts
it was and apparently the investigators
for the Adobe said it they were actually
awesome teams man whatever it takes to
win yeah I'm surprised they don't always
do that that that technology has been
around a long time they you save lip
readers that's why that's why you cover
your mouth that's why coaches cover
their mouths yeah I mean no I mean
Goldberg said he used to read lips Ike
he'd be you know defense and watch them
and he'd be looking to see what the hell
it was
Wow yeah well so when when they were
huddled and he was in defense playing
those guard he'd be watching the
quarterback see what he was saying you
can get to a point where you can do that
feel like you're focusing on the wrong
thing all right you guys this is not
rebelling against you it's against your
dumb friend goal
hey bro you know we love you you're not
a bro right but goes gold no don't go
palace you know he's my buddy you don't
say that dummy no they're lips is head
forget their lips you're mean you look
at the hips square on top you look at
the soul down in there you're it's so
funny to me just go bad on something for
no reason why didn't you hold the door
cuz he's a piece of [ __ ] he should die
what all right check this up Oh Georgia
that's terrifying yeah there's a tiger
on the loose I'll kill you you got out
of the zoo obviously didn't know where
it was from sick so they contact the
sanctuary the local sanctuary that
there's a tiger loose we're gonna bring
him back to you so they started
following the tiger it jumped into some
like persons backyard and attack their
dog so they had to shoot it that's so
stupid you mean tiger doing Tiger [ __ ]
man yeah man asleep anybody they're good
they're they're dead so oh no Larry
Captain Obvious hey let's just go over
to Brandon's and Brian they're gonna
shed swell by because of the clause
correct
do you think it's mostly from the very
razor like sharp toe or from their jaw
tiger cuz they have venomous tail just
over your ass to comment you know
Goldberg says you'd read the lips of the
the quarterback how do I got the place
when it's a circle oh wow it's weird
because they're covered by the biggest
man in the world you can't you know you
don't know and then you know Tigers if
they get a hold of you they will damage
their man-eating animals yeah we've seen
the jungle book that kids movie oh okay
bring up you know Tigers are actually
very dangerous I'm glad he's off the
streets I didn't want to say anything
those things are you know when Tigers
aren't promoting cereal they can be
pretty dangerous all right
oh yeah the one leopard attacks and
kills dog on camera down that that one
watch this
this one yeah watch a dog watches oh boy
this is so wild though I was only 33
seconds yeah
it's so interesting though like how fast
is good
let's keep it up - oh wow doesn't mean
fast at it see you later
that's your dog that's what they do dogs
that was not Tigre Tigre take you out
yeah tiger Tigran your dressing dog city
grand bunnies are be here in a dog suit
a tiger will kill you with their tail
really I did not know that yeah so what
they do is they wrap their tail around
you and then they sting you at the end
of it they are in fact deadly from their
poisonous stinger Tiger Tail waited this
was just a funny headline Otto there's
not much in the story my Tyson says
it'll Bron James blocked his view at me
with him agree he's huge
you see I had to watch like these
ceiling TVs that were tiny but those
zones that were available so he couldn't
watch the fight live because of LeBron
should have been him and look the way I
look at LeBron came in the suit there's
guys exitos at that fight their suits is
nice huh you asking me tough to see over
him yeah Mike is not big either
yeah it's wide those real fake guys now
Mike isn't it's also deadly you wanna
give us a little known fact about Mike
you know Mike could punch pretty well
you get how do you play Mike would fight
in rhythmic circles and if you could
block every third punch and wait for
your power boost to charge up it would
actually get Mac to knock him out your
power boost you would wait for your
green shorts to turn purple my buddy my
buddy actually knock Mike Tyson out my
buddy described an experience with a
girl he goes she's cool man and a wife
cuz I pick her up on a lunch break and
she just gobbled my power source and I
just drop it back off by the way you're
also not a Power Ranger
power so no cob of my power she doubled
my power
source Wow look damn it damn it how old
is he old enough to know better it's a
bum like my age yeah
notice yet to that what the white rapper
half white half black rapper that you
talked about the guy is about suicide
yeah I guess after you sing it on the
VMAs the suicide prevention hotline
their calls went up by 50% large however
the song is the number so I'm guessing
they're just calling the number because
they're curious Oh
so increased suicide prevention so just
graphic we'll have the other track the
logic talk there are one usually long
wait times we like you hang in there
please don't hang up hey I ever been to
Disneyland we get that but the director
said yeah a lot of calls went up and
it's it's great for you know awareness
so o is a good thing yeah that means the
songs worked in yeah oh cool kind of
that's cool do you guys know the
Sudanese rapper bangs yes who he was out
he was a child of war I believe right
yeah and escaped yes yeah what about him
is really cool and well he's kind of a
hit called let me take you to the movies
do you know do you know his name G great
I like names you did at any ones that I
saw did he yeah he was really good
well there there's the long way gone you
know that author long long we gone a
memoir of a hmm well how do you suppose
name yeah I lived bangs maybe with the Z
and then take it to the movies take you
to the movie yeah there you go take you
to the movies not that one yeah yeah
yeah your boy my daughter got mad at me
yesterday and asked me why I wasn't more
like Jimmy Fallon and then she said he's
much better looking I mean I am and she
told me I my teeth are crooked and
yellow oh dear and things just gonna
marry
someday she still is a Fallon fan yes so
they don't have the mail ready to go
right is there just maybe try that
really this first one maybe there maybe
with lyrics and what else you like this
is not the guy that did the yes is not
right it's certainly not the Ted caucus
I knew there was a guy who did I looked
into it was this guy right so this would
mean that Rob's and Brian said he saw
the tent oh this guy's brilliant
wait-listed Rob because you guys are so
awful yeah he's taking them to the movie
so it's very can you read this guy doing
a Ted on my popcorn this is amazing
taking her to the movies and eating
popcorn and they're watching what else
you I'm just saying I know good rap -
yeah and everybody has their taste for
banks not mine but anyway no it's your
boy back help I don't want any said
especially you know at the beginning
didn't say hey girls and then especially
you know but that's for you I don't want
it you Brian Kelly no I don't want it
it's yours
nope from banks I don't know that we're
gonna insult his culture I'm not in so
fingers culture you can't put that on me
insulting the Sudanese I am not sittin
insulting the Sudanese nation I don't
think they should be in the business but
I'm just saying this guy's travelled the
world what do you mean that's the route
can't prove that he raps in front of her
Ferrari and Paris okay
whoever wrapped in front of a Ferrari
and Paris and the pair of skyline I
haven't but it doesn't make him they
obviously had to elevate some sort of
platform now in front of the in front of
the Seine no look at that he got big
money no big money no that's that's
trick photographer you know he can phase
into different shapes and I know that's
not like a Marvel superhero similar take
this off man is too painful and look
nice in New York you've got your
commentary on this it's the best rap
know if that ruined this review man
it's your boy banks and the banking
Tigers in their tails all right Tigers
are deadly you know if bangs fought a
tiger the tiger would probably eat bangs
well no I don't know unless they were at
the movie in the Shaban in this van what
they there aren't Tigers not indigenous
to Africa but they will release a tiger
from the zoo and Sudanese man has to
kill it with a boomerang okay next kind
of it can you type in it's my life
whatever I want to do I don't think so
it's my life yeah whatever I want to do
maybe my favorite YouTube video ever 11
million views singer lyrics music
director he's a multi - it yeah but it's
not a Samba it's my life oh by the way
she's the voice of reason in this whole
thing
so much see she's like weighing in
how about that yeah I mean yeah yeah
real talent real talent real voice and
her opinions of the song I'll only make
you watch until a shot where like her
opinions of the song cannot be hidden
now it's not an actual guitar it's a
synthesized guitar so that means they
took a computer to recreate the sound of
an actual guitar okay the drum fill
[Music]
[Music]
big themes big themes
[Music]
whoa full circle all right so cool you
lovely leave them
[Music]
as sentimental is a different word from
mental but the rhyming syllables are the
exact same waste-fellow the taste of
this fellow well here's the that's where
you drop the beat director drop it
[Music]
now he turns it on though he is wasting
his time
[Music]
so better relationship with his dad than
his mom's yes good okay that doesn't
make sense
I'm a very good bad boy doesn't make
sense to her and they couldn't cut
around it good bad boy see we're messing
with tempo paging right oh that's my
best yeah sure sure
I'm a brain eautiful creepy alright go
for you get that looked at
admirable braggadocious what you've lost
me I need to report you I don't think
you are okay yeah
uber likes oxr oh dear leave only one if
you don't like anyone live alone yes I
fully agree if you don't like anyone you
know
well then because is there our building
1 billion keeps building and then watch
after this after the live forgot about
the Lala's yeah but everything we've
learned all the information all the
knowledge everything he's wanted to
convey about himself thus far yeah so
okay so she's like to live to live well
at least lips see cows also Accord lover
so yeah I hope those ridiculous there's
best song I've ever heard you know or do
you want to hear bangs again no
especially for you yeah but don't Mouse
your food banks your boy banks you've
tortured me enough let me take it to the
moon is your show this typically 40
minutes okay we love you I love you both
so much
thank you Karen killin you guys the best
the movie is killing Gunther killing
Compton September 22nd VOD October 20th
in theaters very except oh it's coming
on brother we should uh we'd like to buy
a drinker
what's middle of the day yeah
I don't know [ __ ] prude
Tarin calaman is a special he's a
beautiful man special person I love him
funny in his sleep well that was our
podcast and if you like if you if if
they want to keep the laughter going
Brendon if they want to keep the
laughter going in September yeah I know
that they could probably if they wanted
go to cobbs September 14th yeah I'm
there next Thursday and then they could
go to Long Beach September the following
week Friday 22nd 22nd at the Laugh
Factory
yeah down along sisters day Long Beach
the following Friday and the 22nd if on
the 22nd or 21st 22nd or 23rd if they're
in Madison Wisconsin they can come see
well they can see me a comedy at stake
my brats my chair brats and beer let's
shove it if you're in Philly on the 28th
29th 30th you can come see me at helium
do it you know I'm saying you take your
tea by Kate calm right now
you bastards uh well that's it buddy
that's another great podcast let's go
watch some more rap videos on YouTube
yeah this is the finally kid we're out